every time
when
yeah Wow
thank you for saying my name five times
okay four times maybe three I don't
remember
what a [ __ ]
I don't even think my name is the ice
always like where's the [ __ ]
butterflies butterflies in my stomach
where are they I need to find them maybe
I can walk in here oh nothing
perfect
maybe back here
but this is like the X oh wait there's
one
Phil I don't need a frickin Bell
okay let's go back [ __ ]
sorry I shouldn't scream like that if I
did that
I just get pissed off when
this part is really creepy like walking
here I would have I would have pissed my
panties what I don't wear panties
or do I I don't know
so we go straight here or maybe back
we could be here
I don't want to see here cuz I never
checked and it would have been annoying
as [ __ ] if it's where I'm just sayin
ya Hossein how am i playing no this is
where the gate was [ __ ]
all right yeah so we need to we need to
continue where do I go I wish someone
were here to help me Maya
yours fat
please run faster it would help me out a
lot
it has to be this way
but it's annoying because I ran
I know your guys are just sitting there
like periodic it is but it's not obvious
it really isn't that obvious you tell me
tell me in the comments what the [ __ ]
I'm gonna supposed to do mm-hmm let's
see what's right and don't cheat I'm
saying we go here we look for stuff
mmm-hmm what about that idea didn't
think of that did he of course he's dead
you're not a genius it's okay I
understand I was born in genius ever
since I was born soon as I came out you
know from when I was born they were like
oh that's genius
right there he's a genius I see it I see
it
genius genius right there geniusness has
been made that's what they said when I
popped out or something probably not
more like oh [ __ ] not I want another one
no I'm just kidding anyway
okay let's go back inside cuz I really
though where I did the priests go like
tell me are they invisible priests I
guess they could be ghosts now that I
think about it but I should be able to
go in here like just bend over a little
that's what he said
anyway directed works pretty well okay
I'll just click everything waked o'clock
nothing is happening
what is this
an old mirror has been enshrined in
front of the altar with a crimson
butterfly picture Oh
now I can't walk there
not down there
I hate that right my wife beautiful
nothing
let me said the word something maybe the
large cotton dress
what am I missing I really don't know
now I looked everywhere
made me walk here twice those [ __ ]
she walks so sweet I love me
perfect
huh
are you saying pity it's obvious if you
are at all okay I'll cry or something
because I don't think it's obvious last
sign
where did the priests go
they were ghosts were anything I think I
know a lot of the place we can go
let's go
I want to know what our characters name
is it's kind of annoying that we don't
know can we go here
okay so let's go back for the second
time cuz why not why the [ __ ] not
wait what is this we can save the
samesies [ __ ]
sings in yeah
I don't even have a memory card hahaha
stupid
company doesn't die or something all
right all right
oh sure album
beautiful look at that photo is gonna be
a cover
yes beautiful how did [ __ ] do I get out
of here okay that's in the game so those
are saved stations and then enough can
we go in here maybe or is it just a wall
yeah it's just a wall
perfect
let's venture further here I think I saw
a room somewhere we can't go there
here's the door
is that something we can pick up nicest
okay I'm pulling a book yes no I said go
creepy
I would never ever ever ever enter a
building like this ever ever ever Oh
movie I love movies actually though can
I take a photo
where is that
cool cool cool movie brah what uh-huh
as a cockroach
it looks like a mine or something
doesn't it yeah so it looks like in mind
uh-huh
can't go everything is locked why why
just show me a crappy movie
shine on knew that was not how are you
sure - singing let's go upstairs so why
not
I'll all been movies how they always
walk upstairs like scary movies when
they go upstairs they always die so I
feel I'm protected my
my you oh sweet I wanna shine Chris so
bless that's probably like what it was
called but anyway of course it's locked
Chris stop glad I have crystal
let's go here then see what's up what's
up
I'm piggy what's figure here I want to
shine on you I have a camera cut bad yes
what is this
lamb-lamb that's all what sir
Flores a guardian needs to said humans
are different in that they are engraved
with shrine maiden's the village
shouldn't say that asaji honest with a
goddess village also a book in the house
links to statues something called
crimson static sacrifice maybe the
forbidden Richard of the rain soon
what's this about a ritual I don't
understand
I think we'll see eventually I think
your rights the phone on what is the
phone on
someone say somehow
that's it yeah he's there of course it's
locked so there's nothing left in there
I think and I love our flashlights never
wrong side of battery it's so annoying
when they add battery game thing or
whatever what oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's so
creepy
I get the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] back oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay the camera loves you yes beautiful
yes can't we slow it down or something
ah [ __ ] is fast [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh okay
photo time it finally we did some damage
she has a lot of life okay
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] fine
I don't want to hug I don't want to
freaking out alright don't have a lot of
health I should really focus that
doesn't no damage at all
oh there it is horshack i'll just
spamming or something I don't know is
this pair of the lemon [ __ ] maybe if I
take a picture of some other area No ah
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] back off
back off
[ __ ] I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die I'm gonna die
okay let's just save states
[Music]
okay it's safe don't worry I want to
[ __ ] this up
[ __ ] it's so creepy it does no damage I
need to use some guidance they'll help I
got full help okay it's a filter or film
or whatever maybe I'll do more damage
done oh come on that [ __ ] [ __ ]
ah he's freaking boss fight there
the camera does not love you
I'm [ __ ] corner - it's so creepy I
cater this wrong pasture
there we go cero shot [ __ ] I don't even
know I doubt what that was but I did it
hey [ __ ] they did nothing well
come on die poor shot what's a Ciro shot
I don't I just keep killing her
okay you then [ __ ] [ __ ] better
recognize she is dead
we should eat something no not take a
photo
she's so [ __ ] bald ass
how do i there we go thank you very much
okay yes okay now we're good
let's go I'm pump what's a piggy maybe
other words open now or something I
don't know yes I'm a genius
I'm a genius
oh wait I'm not the genius I thought I
was genius
okay let's go downstairs so that made
you sad face
mm-hmm I love how I skipped my way down
the Cyrus's like they did did did did
this is where the movie was I really
don't have to go in there
all right here we've been in here
nice nothing here it's just storage I
guess we can leave yes
mm that's another door over there we
should explore that as well
just saying it's important exploring and
staff and this we sure could find the
other statutes getting annoying and I
really don't know where to go they're
fine it's up we'll see maybe it's over
here
my butt hurts [ __ ] get up get up
oh they're just a shiny object there I
need to get it later of course is long
okay that means I have no idea where the
[ __ ] to go I'll take a break here and
maybe I'll figure it out
bye bye